i'm very very sorry that it has come to
this because it
didn't have to be this way um have you
been on the phone to the boss
not yet no this is a fast-moving story i
only found out about this decision
uh earlier this morning and i thought it
was very very important that we make a
very public statement because of the
fury the anger and the upset in the
jewish community
who have had to put up a lot up with a
lot of goings-on in the labour party
that is unacceptable
and i feel i need to remind my
colleagues
you know the labour party is being
investigated by the equalities and human
rights commission
for allegations of institutional
anti-jewish racism
nobody wants that it is a stain on our
party
and for those two nec members to not
take that into account
when they had to recognize the magnitude
of the upset caused by chris williamson
i think
is very very regrettable and it was an
improper
decision and that's why i've taken the
unprecedented step of
putting my name to this public document
they took away
the independence of uh party route and
that's why i agree that the only way we
can solve this now to help rebuild trust
is for jeremy to step in and remove the
whip from chris williamson
yeah he could fix this in a heartbeat
couldn't he i mean he could fix it in
the next hour
well he could remove the whip and that
would allow i think
us to reassure the jewish community that
we take anti-semitism very very quick
very very seriously and i will be
talking to him about it when i
when i get the chance later today okay
and what if he doesn't
if he doesn't i think it will take us
down a road of uh reputation being
eroded in this area
once again you know i i don't want this
century-old institution to be tainted
with the stain of anti-jewish racism and
i'm going to do everything i can to call
it out
which is why i think jeremy will step in
he will understand the magnitude of the
hurt cause
he will know that he's the only one that
can take that decision
he could show that leadership and i hope
very much we can do that very very
quickly to reassure people
that we're actually taking our
anti-semitism problem seriously
and if he doesn't because we know that
you know there's all sorts of
challenges that he's faced in the past
and he's not always stepped up
to the plate when it comes to
allegations of anti-semitism in the
party
if he doesn't uh are you still content
to work with him mr watson
of course i've worked with him we're
elected leader and deputy leader
but i'm not content to sit back and let
racism uh stain the reputation of half a
million labour party members
you know they are hurting
too they feel the pain and the anger
when we fail to deal with racism
properly
they are embarrassed that the jewish
community is so affronted by
a very small number of our members that
we've not been able to deal with
properly
and i should say in this case you know
chris williamson obviously caused
defense
but he does deserve a proper inquiry
and what this committee did was
essentially stop our national
constitutional committee from doing that
inquiry
the only way around that now is to hand
that back to the chief whip who normally
does investigations into mp's conduct
anyway
and that requires jeremy to step in and
authorize that
apparently one of the reasons uh that
they decided
um to bring down this decision is in
case there was a snap election
and they want to make sure that labour
wins that seat
uh i've been speaking to some of your
colleagues this afternoon they're not
very impressed with that
well i've no idea why they made that
decision uh because it was
in my view the wrong one if it was on
those grounds it's obviously
the wrong decision i mean chris
williamson could potentially
be found guilty of anti-jewish prejudice
i'm only saying potentially because he
deserves an inquiry
and we wouldn't want to put a candidate
up a general election
who has been found guilty of that in
inquiry but the jewish community expects
us to take this seriously which is why
there should be a proper investigation
and which is why reluctantly i'm
speaking out publicly now because these
two committee members
have let half a million labour party
members down
in in their decision and it's just wrong